anger against the arrest of Imran Khan
has turned into violent confrontations
with security forces
his Pakistan tarike in South part he
says several people have been killed and
hundreds wounded Han supporters
vandalized buildings and toast vehicles
in several cities
they crossed the red line they shouldn't
expect us to sit quietly after that
we're going to teach them a lesson that
they will remember all their lives we
can besiege any government building at
any time and we are ready to do it
whether they shoot 100 or 300 or a
thousand of us no matter how many party
workers they shoot down we will continue
to protest more Party leaders have been
arrested and are trying to distance
themselves from the destruction
but I've asked them
do not
get into people's houses do not destroy
public or private property but peaceful
protest is our right
these were unprecedented scenes angry
demonstrators storming the Army
Headquarters and commanding officers
homes
[Music]
the military has warned that no further
attacks will be tolerated
it's called Hans party quote a gang
desperate for power dressed in political
garb
the cricketer turned politician is
accused of corruption and misuse of
power the government has denied the
charges are politically motivated and
has warned supporters of Imran Khan
the role of the law means that you fight
for your rights in front of the law and
in court damaging public infrastructure
is an act of terrorism and hostile to
the Homeland I warn these terrorists and
the enemies of the country to
immediately stop their enmity against
the country otherwise the evil people
who underestimate the law will be
brought to Justice and punished based on
the law
as the violence and political tension
escalate people have been caught up in
the chaos
all this is a great nuisance for us
Ordinary People those are blocked
businesses are closed people can't go to
work not everyone is Rich there are poor
people who can't afford to sit at home
the government announced that all
schools should remain open but 99 of the
students can't get to school there are
exams and children will suffer there is
no public transport another intense
round of tear gas shells have been fired
at this crowd blocking the main Highway
towards Islamabad these are the
protesters and that in the distance is
the police line where the shells are
coming in from internet services remain
suspended for an indefinite period and
popular social media sites have also
been blocked as Imran Khan's legal
challenges continue to mount there seems
to be public anger which is boiling over
Islamabad